tourner autour m.  deux choses vont
se passer d'abord ce téléphone là-bas
va sonner ensuite tu vas
porter ces menottes qui diable es-tu
je suis le gars sur qui tu ne comptais pas jack
reacher Purple Heart Silver Star tu es
une légende
il y a ça  la dent et la poussière les gens
disent que vous l'avez fait avec la tête de quelqu'un j'ai
besoin de votre aide
ils ont tué mes hommes des hommes qui étaient
sous votre commandement je sais ce que vous avez
fait
super resté en dehors de cet homme suivi
ici c'était une erreur
vraiment les gars
maintenant  J'ai l'impression que vous
appréciez cette
façon très intéressante de dire merci
désolé qu'il ne se sente pas peut vouloir utiliser
cela
vous